no no I care about Aesthetics it  shouldn't take 28 minutes to make a bed  I agree how many pillows do you want on  your bed we got like eight pillows  that's a lot for a clean a lot no trays  with candles and [ __ ] decorative  books she really has that on the bed at  all God damn right and I hate my [ __ ]  [ __ ] on it in the middle of night I'm  like oh God [ __ ] Bell and there's no  light sources in the room my eyes  already suck ass during the day by the  way what does the tray do let's just  hold candles candles that you don't like  and also there's like four books like  architectural design nobody read it  women through the 19 [ __ ] 30s for the  50s nobody ever read it ever I know what  you're talking about all the women  it's all in my stupid tray on the  [ __ ] foot of my bed but for her she  could stretch out oh like this  good morning but me just getting into  bed God damn it oh my [ __ ] God I  broke a bone why my marriage on the  [ __ ] wrong